bonjour louis boutrin bonjour président
du parc naturel régional de martinique
merci d'être d'entre dans son caddie
plus de moi que la grève court au parc
ce matin encore la cdmt déplore la
présence de vigiles et deux chiens
abords du site de cette catherine une
réunion vendredi du conseil syndical qui
n'a pas permis de rapprocher les lignes
la situation s'enlise chacun reste sur
ses positions
franchement louis boutrin on ne voit pas
comment on va s'en sortir dans cette
affaire permettez tout d'abord monsieur
le temps que je puisse saluer vos
auditeurs et surtout les 149 à jean
dupas
quand je dis 149 cd 130 agents n'aurait
et vi est également les 19 agents
grévistes et je profite pour la sono 19
je profite pour lancer un appel solennel
à la reprise du travail à la sérénité et
afin que effectivement on puisse
retourner à un fonctionnement normal de
38 joueurs que il n'écoute pas votre
appel où il votera parce qu'ils veulent
négocier
monsieur viol dont il y à une décision
du juge des référés que je vous ai
apporté ce matin et le juge des référés
demande à la froid à monsieur bri mer et
à la centrale démocratique martiniquaise
des travailleurs
la cdmt ctm non représentés au niveau du
parc de quitter les lieux de libérer des
accès de quitter les lieux or ce matin
qu'est ce qu'on apprend qu'il y a
effectivement des syndicalistes de la
cdmt qui sont dans un piquet de grève
devant le siège du parc naturel vous
trouvez que c'est normal que des
décisions dans un état de droit que des
décisions ne soient pas respectés
monsieur bouton vous trouvez ça soit
normal qu'il y ait une violence et que
par des reportages complaisant par des
propos complaisants on contribue à une
certaine victimisation des fauteurs de
troubles mais vous traite de la violence
on évoque également mais de votre part
de par votre attitude que les grévistes
avaient juge condescendant vous êtes un
homme peu ouverts au dialogue distillant
la terreur et c'est ce qu'ils disent je
lui dise monsieur nona du cas du seul
hector général des services il estime
que vous n'êtes pas un homme de dialogue
nourri bon train alors vous avez été
destinataire monsieur viol ton de ce
pavé qui a été rédigé par le directeur
général des services
c'est un courrier qui se veut anonyme
vous m'avez appelé tout de suite après
pour me demander effectivement une
interview giraud fusée parce que ce pavé
est envoyé à l'ensemble des élus ce
palais est envoyé aux syndicalistes et
aux journalistes et vous perdez en
quelques pas en cause ibilité quand vous
reprenez des propos parce qu'il ya un
principe qu'il faut respecter sur le
possible regret c'est d'avoir reconnu
que je vous ai quand même tout de suite
appelé vous payez votre ampli et qu'est
ce qu'il dit et on s'adresse directement
sur vos têtes
anonyme qu'est ce qu'on constate dans
cet anonyme il y à une quarantaine de
points le 21e point le 8 août
envoi sous les réseaux sociaux via web
apps par le directeur de rld m nier que
m'a adressé le président qui fait état
de mon salaire
voilà une dette qui se veut anonyme où
l'auteur conjugue maladroite mal le
vivable à la première personne du
singulier
ce qui veut dire vous avez d'emblée une
attitude partisane c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure monsieur viol
tanger une attitude on a une culture
l'existence est de plus en plus de
revenir vous expliquer c'est vous avez
refusé à l'époque aussi s'est vu mettre
les points sur les i d'autres et cette
culture ne fait pas conseillé de venir à
l'époque parce que il s'agit pas de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu conteneurs
effet sur les résultats
quant à ce qui se passe sur les réseaux
sociaux des deux côtés on a inondé et
arrosé par l de contrat tout à fait
alors revenons en venant c'est le
remercie de la cdmt puisque vous ne
voulez pas entendre les agents non
grévistes qui nous arrive nous sommes
arrivés de l'est compte également 90
vous ne les avez monde est invité jamais
il y a deux syndicats qui sont
représentés depuis les élections du 4
décembre 2014
à quel moment on les a sollicités
également quel dommage pour qu'ils
puissent s'exprimer à sollicite
également si aujourd'hui les agents
quand les agents sont débauchés camp
ont confisqué les clés on firme les clés
et combes et de la colle dans les
serrures
quand on empêche aux agents d'accéder à
leur lieu de travail
vous trouvez ça normal mais si on
continue comme ça où ça notamment permis
c'est l'amant de votre visite
permettez il faut qu'on fasse attention
à cette espèce d'excusés et de
victimisation que l'on à des fauteurs de
trouble parce que c'est ces violences on
les retrouve dans l'institution scolaire
on les retrouve enseignants et enfants
sont victimes
on retrouve au niveau de sa plongée dans
les éditions poteau égal mais également
dans les institutions alors que font les
institutions parce que à la cité m quand
on défonce l'atrium avec un pick up
quand on est responsable pas mais oui
mon nom n'y arrive pas ce qu'ils font
écouter ce message aussi monsieur viol
ton à ce qu'on peut lire une inspection
générale l'institution à une publication
de se protéger de protéger ses agents
c'est ce qu'a fait monsieur marie-jeanne
lors des deux derniers en plein air
c'est ce que je fais ce matin au niveau
du siège du pas fort de ce constat
d'huissier et de décisions des tribunaux
alors depuis votre arrivée au pouvoir au
parc ou ailleurs n'a eu cesse de
dénoncer des dérives allant voir et
c'est vraiment sur le parc on n'a eu
cesse de vous m'avez eu cesse de
dénoncer des dérives financières des
budgets mbale contrôler une opacité dans
les recrutements fait avant votre
arrivée
louis boutrin le dgs on a huit maires
selon vous serait le symbole de tout
cela dit nous ce matin dans son coin
alors si vous parlez de dérive
financière
j'espère pour vous que vous savez au
début de la mandature en 2010 quand
madame angela a quitté des affaires il y
avait soixante neuf agents on est passé
de 69 à 174 agents ce qui veut dire
qu'il ya une conséquence directe la
masse salariale on est passé de 2
millions 3 de masse salariale dans le
budget de fonctionnement
pas plus de 4 millions 8 est la veille à
travers une transaction selon le votre
prédécesseur daniel chomet de nos
actions joe grass de grâce là encore je
vous le dis si jamais il y avait des
dérives financières
c'est d'aidé financière aux héritiers
serait passé sous les fourches caudines
du contrôle de légalité par le
il fait et en cas de dérive financière
vous le savez pour toutes les
collectivités
il ya une sanction qui est la sanction
par la chambre régionale des comptes
alors il n'appartient pas à vous abonner
ses propos du djs qui a bercé par une
hacienda aux djs d'exercer un contrôle
d'opportunité sur des délibérations
d'élus
quand on a voté un budget quand on a
voté un conte qu'administratif
effectivement nous c'est un acte
politique
l'ajustement jeu là c'est une affaire
politique cette histoire finalement
loutre mais écoutez on est en plein dans
une affaire politique parce qu'on ne
parle plus une opposition même où
certains de leurs je suis je suis désolé
monsieur viol ton à quel moment
m'avez-vous interrogé sur effectivement
le bien fondé de cette sanction
disciplinaire parce que écouté calmement
monsieur le juge s il n'est c'est un
agent contractuel de droit public en
vous révélations qui à rené ce qu'on
vous a posé la question à l'emploi
fonctionnel et un emploi fonctionnel en
qualité de dg s et comme on le sait ces
emplois fonctionnels
c'est un emploi qualifié de
discrétionnaire et d'essentiellement
révocable ce qui veut dire que au lieu d
être à disposition du centre de gestion
au début quand je te remettre une
proposition quand je suis arrivé aux un
film me pose la question est ce que j'ai
l'intention de le garder moi je ne fais
pas de chasse aux sorcières
je fais confiance à la compétence je
fais confiance au respect ce seront les
remercier parce qu'il n'est pas
compétent pour vous qu'est ce que vous
nous dites ce matin oui mais vous dites
ce que vous voulez je vous pose la
question je vous réponds je vous pose la
question n'a jamais et tu ne fait pas de
faux débat parce qu'il n'a jamais été
question de la compétence le monsieur
bettmer dans ce dossier
ce qu'il est ce qu'il est il est
question aujourd'hui c'est le fait
qu'ils respectent pas les délibérations
des élus et que quand le dgs ne met pas
en oeuvre des décisions des
délibérations ou des missions qui
relèvent de son contrat de travail
la commune est si loin des nations et
cette insubordination je suis désolé
c'est le code général des collectivités
à disposition du centre de gestion le
remplacer par tête le d'autres monsieur
relever l'imposition monsieur viol dont
il ya eu plusieurs propositions dès
qu'elle est le pont le président marie
jeanne a même fait une proposition à
monsieur huit maires
pour qu'il soit effectivement qui lui
viennent à la ctm il a refusé cette
proposition que ces propositions il n'y
a pas eu de dialogue avec le public mais
qui a déclaré dans le foie senti que le
combat le plus important ce combat
politique depuis quand un digest peut
avoir autant de manquement à ses devoirs
de à ses obligations de neutralité pour
dire que c'est un combat politique nous
aujourd'hui ce qu'on dit il ya deux
possibilités pour effectivement
remercier un dgs soit en rupture de
confiance ça se fait classiquement ou là
pour une faute disciplinaire
c'est une faute disciplinaire qui
sanctionnait maintenant je répète nous
sommes dans un état de droit et il faut
rappeler aux djs ses doigts il a la
possibilité de saisir la juridiction
compétente pour défendre ses intérêts or
ce n'est pas ce qu'il a choisi
vous avez bien vu outre cette violence
que nous avons tout autour de cette
affaire ce que je dis aujourd'hui je
lance un appel solennel à ce qu'il y ait
une sérénité et je lance un appel à la
fois aux syndicats mais également
monsieur vite les intrigues pour qu'il
puisse dire à ses amis d'arrêter parce
que le mois de le mois d'octobre ces 430
milles le onze salles et envers ses
verso un travail non effectué ce sont
des rssi débris sont bloqués et des
recettes en moins selon la police 800
cas dit c'était avec louis boutrin le
président du parc naturel régional de
martinique merci bonne journée
[Musique]